- We're told that Casey buys a bracelet.
She pays for the bracelet and
pays 72 cents in sales tax.
The sales tax rate is 6%.
What is the original price
of the bracelet, before tax?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure this out.
Well, let's think about how
your sales tax is calculated.
Your sales tax would be
equal to the sales tax rate,
I'll just call that the
rate, so that's going to be
equal to the rate times
your original price.
And what do we know here?
Well they tell us what our sales tax is.
Our sales tax is 72 cents,
so I'll write that here.
So 72 cents is going to be
equal to my sales tax rate,
they also tell us that, that is 6%,
is going to be equal to
6% times my original price
and that's what they're asking
for, the original price.
So times, I'm just going
to call it P for short,
original price.
And so you have it.
We have a fairly
straightforward equation now.
And now I'm just going to
rewrite everything as decimal,
so we could write 0.72 is equal to 6%
is the same thing as six per 100,
which is the same thing as six hundredths,
0.06, six hundredths times p.
And now we can just divide
both sides by six hundredths
to solve for the original
price, so let's do that.
Alright.
So on the right-hand side I have a P.
On the left-hand side
if I have 72 hundredths
divided by six hundredths,
well that's going to be
equal to 12, 12 times six is 72.
Six hundredths times 12
would be 72 hundredths.
And so this is going to be equal to 12.
So the original price of the
bracelet, before tax is $12.
And you can verify that.
6% of $12, 0.06 times 12
is indeed 72 hundredths.
Let's do another example.
A store has a 25% off sale on coats.
With this discount, the
price of one coat is $34.50.
What is the original price of the coat?
So once again, pause this video
and see if you can figure it out.
These examples, they're
actually quite useful
because you will encounter
this all of the time
when you are shopping or
you're trying to calculate tax
or you're buying something,
so think about this.
Can you figure out the
original price of the coat?
Alright, well let's just write it out
the same way we did last time.
Let's say our original
price and then there's a 25%
discount, so minus 25%
of the original price
is going to be equal to $34.50
because that the price with the discount.
So can we solve for the original price?
So one way to think about it, this is 100%
of the original price or
one times the original price
minus 25% of the original
price is going to equal this.
Well, 100% minus 25% of
something is going to be 75%
of our original price,
this is why people use
letters for variables,
so they don't have to keep
writing this over and over again,
is going to be equal to $34.50.
Now to solve for our
original price we just divide
both sides by 75%.
And 75%, that's the same thing as
75 per 100 or 75 hundredths.
So I could divide both
sides by 75 hundredths.
On the left-hand side
these two are equivalent,
so I'll be left with my original price.
And now I just have to figure
out what is this going to be.
So if I take 75 hundredths
and let me actually
multiply both of these times 100.
So this is going to be the same thing as
3,450 divided by 75.
I just did that to get
rid of the decimals.
I moved, essentially, both of the decimals
to the right two places.
Multiplying the numerator
and the denominator by 100.
So let's see how many
times 75 goes into 3,450.
Let's see, 75 doesn't go into three.
Doesn't go into 34.
It does go into 345.
What is that, four times?
Four times five is 20.
Four times seven is 28 plus two, 300.
And then you subtract.
Get 45.
Bring down the zero.
450.
75 goes into 450 six times.
Six times five is 30.
Six times seven is 42
plus three is indeed 45
and we luckily have no remainder.
So this right over here is
going to be equal to $46.
Our original price is $46.
You take off one-fourth or
25%, you're left with $34.50.
And that makes intuitive sense as well.
Always good to just take
whatever answer you have
and put it back in and
see if it makes sense.
In terms of if you somehow
got $460 and you said taking
25% off you get to $34.50, you'd
say "Well that sounds off."
Or if you got $4 and you
said you take 25% off
and you got $34.50 that
would have also felt off,
but $46 feels right.
And you can even calculate that.
What's 25% of $46, subtract that from $46
and you should get $34.50.